المرشح الابرز للحزب الجمهوري يواجه
منافسه قويه مع مرشحين جمهوريين اخرين في
السباق الرئاسي الامريكيه العام المقبل
ابرزهم مايك بنس نائب الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب
مرشح جمهوري اخر هي نكهالي والتي كانت
حاكمه سابقه لولايه كارولاينا الجنوبيه
وسفيره ترامب السابقه لدى الامم المتحده
عندما كان رئيسا للولايات المتحده كما
اعلن الحاكم السابق لنيوجيرسي كريستي
دخوله السباق الى البيت الابيض مقدما نفسه
على انه الجمهوري الوحيد القادر على
مواجهه ترامب حليفه السابق الذي اصبح من
اشد خصومه الان في ما رد ترامب على ترشيح
كريستي بالقول انه حاكم فاشل
في القائمه كذلك حاكم ولايه فلوريدا راندي
سانتوس المرشح الثاني الاوفر حظا بعد
ترامب بحسب استطلاعات الراي
وبعد ترشح ديسانتوس بشكل رسمي قالت ترامب
عنه انه سيحتاج الى عمليه زرع شخصيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات